the USSR was notably the second Nation
to build and detonate nuclear weapons
with them following the United States by
four years but given the devastation
that the USSR had suffered during the
second world war how did it build such
an expensive weapon how did the Soviet
Union get its first nukes so as most of
you will know the idea of splitting the
atom and making nuclear weapons was not
a new one as of 1945. the problem was
that the process would be incredibly
expensive and the USSR didn't exactly
have a lot of spare change as such no
nuclear program would begin in Earnest
until the Germans were defeated but that
doesn't mean that the Soviets weren't on
the lookout for other nations trying to
build the bomb and it didn't take long
for the USSR to work out that the
Americans were trying to build one the
first way they learned was that American
scientists stopped publishing papers on
nuclear topics and the second way was
good old-fashioned Espionage notably via
the British delegation to the American
nuclear project who would report back to
Moscow so it's that simple right the
Soviets simply stole all of the details
from the Americans and reverse
engineered the bomb four years later
allow us know whilst the USSR did make
use of spies and informants embedded in
the Manhattan Project that doesn't mean
that they trusted a single word that
they said the ussr's nuclear program at
first fell under leverenty barrier the
head of Soviet intelligence and he was
to be frank quite paranoid which was
understandable given that he'd only
gotten his job after his predecessor had
gotten thoroughly starlined as such he
didn't want to make any mistakes and so
for the most part assumed that the
Allies were using double agents to feed
him misinformation with that in mind
Soviet scientists were tasked with
trying to figure out the theory of the
bomb from scratch and they weren't
particularly hopeful that was until
Hiroshima a Nagasaki at which point
mines became much more focused Stalin
ordered that the project be massively
scaled up and given any money that it
needed and these funds were taken from
all across the Soviet budget this was
easy to justify for the politbury's
members because as far as they were
concerned if the USSR didn't build
nuclear weapons it was doomed the
problem for the USSR wasn't a lack of
know-how or an issue with the logistics
of such a large project it was the lack
of nuclear material uranium suitable for
use in the bomb had been monopolized by
the British and the Americans and the
USSR didn't know if there was any
suitable uranium within its own borders
and thus it had to go with plutonium
which it had plenty of in the Euros but
mining it would be far too expensive
after the destruction of the war not
unless they could find a nearly unending
source of cheap labor that was oh wait
so with the plutonium being mined the
program could go ahead scientists were
told to build the bomb from scratch and
the intelligence gathered from the
United States was used to check the
Project's progress the Soviets also made
use of German scientists to help who
were borrowed after the war but they
were kept in a different facility away
from everybody else the project
continued to grow until 1949 at which
point more than half a million people
had contributed and as the bomb got
closer to completion the Soviets decided
to copy the American bomb casing instead
of using their own because if it failed
and the Americans found out it would
look embarrassing the test worked the
Americans found out anyway and after
this the Cold War truly began in Earnest
with both Powers then racing to see who
could build the first Hydrogen Bomb I
hope you enjoyed this episode with the
special thanks to my patrons James
bisonet Kelly moneymaker kosher wolf
cartoitska Alex Schwinn Andy mcgehi
Jerry lambdin rod D Martin a firefly
Marcus arsner why in hockey Spencer
Lightfoot Marvin Castle Captain said
okamoon Yoon Winston K would miss izep
buggly Wiggly Maggie pascowski the
macquapa Gustav Swan calling Dr Howard
Dr Fine Dr Howard Coppertone she went in
spinning three plates words about books
podcast Jim Stromberg words about books
podcast and Charles the first